welcome back while the southern border
as we know is overrun by migrants it's
not the only place in america seeing an
influx of refugees
the welcome mat is officially now being
laid out for migrants coming from
afghanistan
according to the department of homeland
security today a flight carrying 75
unaccompanied afghan children
landed in the glamorous city
of chicago
this number is in addition to the 860
afghan refugees that the state of
illinois is already planning on
welcoming in the coming weeks
with 550 of those
being children
and to be clear the vast majority of
this group does not include the brave
interpreters who went through the
special immigrant visa process and were
vetted after fighting alongside american
troops against the taliban
these are at-risk kids
many without parents or sponsors waiting
for them in the windy city
meaning they will be wards of the
government
which can't even take care of the kids
already living in chicago
a city that has already seen at least
261 kids shot alone this year
not to mention a city where 80 percent
of eighth graders don't read at grade
level
taking in kids from a country with a 38
literacy rate and trust me that number
is generous
so chicago can't even take care of its
own kids and we expect chicago to take
care of parentless afghan children
what in the world could go wrong
joining me now is victor davis hanson
he's the author of the upcoming book
the dying citizen and i do very much
look forward to reading it everything
you say victor is thoughtful on
in this particular case
we welcome
afghans who fought alongside us we also
know that the vast majority that came
are coming or headed to our country
weren't in that category per se they
were at risk now you've got kids going
to chicago do we have a system
set up to absorb them properly
no i don't think so i think children in
chicago who are us citizens will fare
worse
than even refugees we're kind of like
the 19th century british empire that had
a fort or a base all over the world but
charles dickens was writing at home
about the poverty and crime at the heart
of it all in london that's what's
happened we've hollowed out our cities
and yet we think we can spread all of
our culture where uh fly pride flags and
have george murrell's
george floyd murals in the streets of
kabul but we're hollowed out at home i
think it's kind of a war on citizenship
because
the the soldiers who are asked to
accompany the refugees even if they've
had antibodies and a prior case of code
they're going to have to get vaccinated
but people coming in from afghanistan or
the 2 million at the border even if they
haven't had cover they won't ask to be
vaccinated and you and i uh p we can't
pick and choose which laws we follow
people come across the border
the first thing they do is break the law
the second thing they do is break the
law by residing here probably the third
will be some type of id we just can't
say i'm not going to pay i'm not going
to follow an irs law i don't like this
federal gun registration law so i'm
going to avoid it
and
dan don gino mentioned the fact that
when i come in the united states i'm
paranoid about making sure i have my
passport i'm a citizen non-citizens
don't worry about that apparently it's
part of a larger project i think the
democratic and left-wing agenda movement
project whatever we call it is unhappy
with the present electorate we have
about 50 million people that were not
born in the united states that are now
residing here legally and if illegal
they think we've got to change the
demography because we don't get 51
support percent support for our agenda
and that's sort of the organic argument
that flipped
california nevada colorado maybe arizona
new mexico maybe someday georgia and
then the elites say well we've got to
change the electorate but we've also got
to get a get rid of the nine person
supreme court the electoral college the
filibuster get a national voting law get
two more states but it's part of a
larger effort
that says under the existing system and
rules and under the existing electorate
and demography we can't get what we want
so we're going to change both at the
opposite ends and that's what they're
doing victor real quick we only have
about 45 seconds but do they believe
that these kids will succeed when they
get here or do they know
the system will fail them and as you
pointed out they're just not that
concerned about it
no i think they think so i wouldn't be
surprised if the social workers focus on
them in a greater
fashion than they do the uh underclass
of chicago we have this strain i don't
know what it is it's some kind of weird
cultural tick that if you're not a
citizen and you're coming into the
country
uh even without legality or maybe not
through the the legal lengthy process
we're going to do all we can for you in
a way that we've kind of abandoned our
own i don't know how else to explain it
because if you're a young
african-american child
uh growing up in chicago i think we're
going to give you your parents some
money or subsidies but we're really out
of out of sight out of mind we don't
really care about you that's a terrible
thing to say but i think that's our
attitude but we prefer
people from another country than we do
our own citizens that's a good point
that's kind of a commentary where we are
it's it's the it's the exact opposite of
america first it's precisely what it is
when you don't believe in yourself you
look somewhere else victor david's
handsome
citizenship last yeah look forward to
the book as well thank you so much for
the time hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else